for many a century
mankind has driven to understand what
space is made of
and if a measly hundred years ago this
information was confined exclusively to
theory
today thanks to advanced telescopes
we're able to see many parts of the
universe around us
for the first time as the picture of the
closest areas of space gained in detail
the observer would again and again
invariably encounter phenomena
whose nature would prove to be harder to
identify
many of these are still able to leave
the entire scientific community at a
loss
for example imagine one of the most
exotic and bizarre objects in the
universe
a celestial body previously unknown to
science
a binary system spewing out jets of mata
at a speed reaching a quarter of the
speed of light
this is a micro quasar dubbed ss433
as a rule micro quasars are x-ray
binaries
that is stellar systems made up of two
components
one of them is a regular star similar to
our sun
the other component is a compact object
like a black hole or a neutron star
matter in such micro quasars is
constantly in the process of
accumulating in the compact object which
is accompanied by occasional
outflows of matter at great speeds
these outflows are known as jets and the
nature of these jets reminds one of
processes taking place in regular
quasars
now it is not a regular occurrence in
ordinary quasars
meanwhile as the mass of a micro quasar
is smaller than that of an ordinary
quasar jets may originate here
practically on a daily basis
the principal difference between micro
quasars and ordinary quasars is in their
mass
and the frequency of matter outflows
for example the mass of the compact
components and micro quasars is
considerably smaller than the mass of
those in regular quasars
it is just several cellular masses just
to compare
the average mass of a supermassive black
hole in the center
of a quasar maybe approximately as much
as a hundred million solar masses
as for the mass of the black hole likely
to be found in the center of ss-433
it must be just a few dozen solar masses
the accretion disk of a micro quasar is
intensely luminescent
with emissions in the optical and x-ray
bands
a regular quasar is an astronomical body
boasting the highest luminosity among
other objects in the observable
universe according to contemporary
scientific views
these celestial bodies are active cores
of galaxies where a supermassive black
hole
sucks in matter all around it thus
forming an accretion disk
as for the disk itself it is a source of
very powerful luminosity
just to give you an idea its luminosity
may sometimes be hundreds of times as
intense as that of all stars in a galaxy
like ours
combined to date over 200
000 quasars have been identified
we're able to observe some of these
quasars in the sky
even without using a telescope and so
the rate of discovering new objects of
one or the other category is another
principle parameter by which regular
quasars and micro quasars differ
if we look at the list of known micro
quasars it contains just a few entries
so far
the first micro quasar was discovered
back in 1978
when a source of unusual radio and x-ray
emissions was detected by two
astronomers from the university of
cambridge
as they were looking for debris left
over from supernovae
detected in the constellation aquila
this source was later dubbed
ss433
the object under scrutiny is an
eclipsing x-ray binary system
one of its components is likely to be a
black hole
as for the second component it is a star
of spectral type a
that is a main sequence dwarf star of a
whitish hue
it is assumed that this star's mass is
10 to 30 times that of our sun
and more likely than not the dwarf used
to be considerably heavier in the
earlier stages of its existence
its surface temperature is thought to be
anything from 7
000 to half 11.5 degrees kelvin
this temperature range is typical for
stars of this type
it is actually its temperature that
gives the star its pale
yellow tint in fact if we look at the
stars closest to the sun
then sirius altair and viega fall into
the same class as this star
ss-433 is located within the supernova
remnant
w-50 sometimes also called the manatee
nebula
the age of this nebula is estimated at
approximately 20
000 years and the distance between the
nebula and the earth measures about 18
000 light years the jets from ss433
distort the clouds surrounding the w-50
nebula
according to a certain theory the w50
nebula and the micro quasar ss-433
are actually related and came to be as a
result of one in the same supernova
event
which supposedly took place around 20
000 years ago
it takes either of the two objects in
the system 13.1 days to orbit the common
mass center
in fact the way the ss433 system works
is quite exciting
with both components constantly
interacting with each other
mata from the second component that is
the regular star
flows to the first component or the
primary supposedly a black hole
thus forming an accretion disk around it
as it spirals
the matter heats up to extreme
temperatures and emits x-rays
some part of the smatter leaves the
system in two jets
at the rate of approximately 26 percent
of the speed of light
that is 79 000 kilometers per second
in 2019 thanks to the alma observatory
astronomers managed to get detailed
images of ss-433
it was clear from the emission structure
that the micro quasars jets themselves
are rather narrow
and their shape is irregular and has
nodes
further studies of the object showed
that the shape of the jets is distorted
as a result of precession that is a
process when the jets
slowly rotate on their axis as they
spiral
the diameter of either of the two jets
ejected from the micro quasar in two
opposite directions
measures approximately 5000 times the
diameter of the solar system
as ss-433 is relatively close to the
earth it is particularly valuable to
scientists studying the phenomenon of
micro quasars
images beamed back by the alma
observatory showed its jets for the
first time
and it also helped establish the
direction these jets point out is never
the same
just like a top the spinning toy
gradually slows down
they too rotate on their axis which is
perpendicular to the plane of the
accretion disk
the armor images boasted another
outstanding feature
the shape of ss-433 was predicted in
fine detail thanks to spectroscopic
measurements that had been done in 2018
using the global jet watch telescopes
and so the actual shape largely
corresponds to the new images
where ss433 is really seen to have a
shape reminding one of a corkscrew
it isn't a rare occasion when jets like
that originate here or there
in the universe as a rule jets of plasma
also known as relativistic jets are
spewed out of the centers of active
galaxies
quasars and radio galaxies
when this occurs there are usually two
jets as such
pointing in the opposite directions and
this is exactly what we can observe in
the case of ss-433
today the phenomenon of jets like that
wants deeper studying
it is believed that jets originate
following the interaction between
magnetic fields and the accretion disk
around a black hole or a neutron star
as for their size it may be staggeringly
enormous
in the case of the radio galaxy 3c120
for example
the jet stretches for at least several
kilopass
away from its source it is highly
probable that in the future the regular
star in the ss433 system will shed its
outer layer completely
as a result of the influence of the
compact object
its core meanwhile will remain hot and
thus the star will qualify to be called
a hot sub dwarf
later the star is to be gradually sucked
in by the black hole
and sooner or later after this process
is completed
the ss433 system will assume a classical
look
it will comprise just the compact object
the process of this system's evolution
will of course continue for thousands of
years
so we have plenty of time to study this
phenomenon
and while the micro quasar ss-433 is
active
we will have many opportunities to carry
out detailed observation
that would help us understand the nature
of this celestial object
let's keep in touch
you